let's get to the games packers 12 and
three bears eight and seven green bay
clinches a first round bye with a
victory or a loss by the seattle
seahawks see the packers only blow the
um the
the one seed if they get into a
three-way tie right with green bay
seattle and new orleans if it's a
two-way tie with green bay and
uh seattle or green bay and new orleans
green bay is in i think they also lose a
two-way tie with seattle so so
regardless green bay likely to win green
bay likely to get in but chicago needs
the win to get into the playoffs they
may back in with an arizona loss
this is aaron rodgers and this is aaron
rodgers understanding he just saw on
sunday night the value
of home field advantage exactly right
when that snowstorm comes through i even
though the bears are prone to periodic
or the packers excuse me a periodic what
the hell happened we didn't show up
today i don't see that happening on
sunday they know the importance of this
game they're getting a 13 and three matt
lafleur is getting to 26 and six and
they're getting that one seed i i would
think so i mean that's certainly what
i'm thinking right now
i mean i think you said it right the
first thing that comes to my mind is
just hey they aaron rodgers
ended last year talking about
we need to get home playoff games that
was what they talked about ending the
year last year after they uh they they
lost and and were knocked out who the
heck were they knocked out by i can't
even remember now but either way i know
that was a big conversation and a
talking point that we got to get these
games at home because they are a
different football team you can see the
elements were into their favor the other
night definitely and
rogers of course because he's such a
pure thrower the football like a brady
or a mahomes
you know he he welcomes the five degree
day in green bay because he just goes
i'm gonna throw lasers in perfect
spirals i don't care if it's five or
eighty-five and the other quarterback
comes in and it's like whoa this ball is
slick and hard and holy crap my hands
are dry and i can't grip this thing and
it hurts when i'm catching it here in
warm-ups and everything and you know
guys get off kilter that way so i you
know i'm with you i expect green bay
chicago is different and we know that
their offense is different but chicago's
defense hasn't been as dominant lately
mike that that would to me be the most
concerning thing about the match-up
right now with what rogers did to them
the first time around and just the way
they've looked i i worry about that for
chicago bears and that's weird to say
it really is amazing what the packers
have done when you consider all the
questions that were swirling when matt
lafleur became the coach would he be
able to handle aaron rodgers and this
year would the team would anyone with
the organization would would
would they be able to deal with and
aaron rodgers who was upset about the
jordan love situation we know he's upset
because brett favre was his surrogate
who made it clear he was upset in the
aftermath of the draft and yeah
i'm no packers fan but i know exactly
who they've lost to the last two years
that's how few games they lost they lost
two the eagles the chargers the 49ers
49ers again in the postseason and this
year the vikings the buccaneers and the
cults and and they've only lost one
regular season game at home which shows
you the value of the road to the super
bowl going through lambeau field so we
go to soldier field this weekend and the
bears are just gonna have to hope that
what the cardinals lose i don't know why
there's so many these different i know
possibilities i i feel like i every time
i say it i'm never 100 confident that
i'm right but i think if the cardinals
lose the bears are in no matter what
you're right 50 times this week no but i
still don't feel 100 confident about it
because there's all these different
moving parts that are they're all
i've never i don't remember a year like
this where there's this many different
moving parts that you can't keep
straight yeah it's uh it did i i
understand what you're going through
because you're right i've had to say it
a few times this week too where i've
second guess like wait am i right about
that but yes
yeah you said it right the bears can
lose and still get in if arizona loses
to the los angeles ramp so there is that
aspect and honestly it's kind of what
i'm expecting to happen i don't know how
you feel about it but that's the way i'm
kind of leaning at this moment and then
you know hey last thing i want to say
about green bay and just this matchup
all together because talk about chicago
you know their defense people have been
running the football on them
chicago i mean green bay on offense
for me has become a different team here
the last few weeks with what they're
doing on the run game on the offensive
side of the ball you know they've become
a true force in my opinion you know
before i know they ran the ball well
last year and they had moments this year
but i still think it was all predicated
at least in my studies and opinion on
you know hey teams were rogers rogers
rogers teams were worried about stopping
rogers rogers rogers and then he would
get in a running play and oh they're
playing past defense and they'd be good
that way but that i always felt like
when teams played run they couldn't just
you know impose their physical will in
the run game
that's changed that's made me think a
little differently of green bay going in
the playoffs you know they're they're
lining up times now and just rogers
knows the run game's working the defense
might be playing a run defense and they
just say screw you we're going to run it
and they get yards that's where they're
getting scary and that's where they gash
the bears i can't believe i'm saying
this but the bears have no chance of
winning this game unless they go all in
to stop the run if they play it the
first way or like they did the first
time around where they tried to play
like we're going to try to stop a little
bit of everything they're not going to
stop anything and it's going to be 40
points on the board
you know right now with the way they're
playing i take my thing and go i'm gonna
stop the run and it's not an overly
complicated pass game and i'm gonna
trust some of my secondary and my
coaching through the week to maybe slow
down that aspect but i'm more worried
about aaron jones and and dylan and the
way they look right now and that's where
i got started for the packers in that
first game against the bears over the
last five weeks third in the nfl in
average yards rushing
per game we mentioned cardinals rams
cardinals eight and seven at the nine
and six rams john wolford get it right
coaches wolford is quarterback for the
rams and it's presumably kyler murray
although he's got a leg injury he may be
not the same kyler murray that we're
used to seeing desperation for the
cardinals winning their inn losing their
out rams still get in if the bears
lose to the packers um
can the rams pull this off with all
these injuries that they have can they
beat the arizona cardinals chris i do
think so i do yeah i think the rams
really are a tough matchup for the
arizona cardinals they're just you know
again and
this week for my podcast i went back and
watched all these games their first
matchups first time around you know the
rams really hey they were built in part
what to stop russell wilson in the
seattle seahawks well kyla murray kind
of fits that mold to a degree too and
the rams
you know they love playing spread
football oh you want to play spread
football they're they're all about that
they're not a big team they're a speed
team their rams are arguably the fastest
defense in the game so you know them
containing kyler murray and running him
down no problemo they're not going to
have any issues with that you know where
i would worry about the rams is in like
phone booth football oh power run games
stuff like that that's where they've
struggled this year and that's where i
look at the cardinals and just think if
they think they're going to spread and
kyler murray is going to scramble and
run around and they're just going to
throw balls to deandre hopkins no they
have aaron donald to stop kyler murray
they got jalen ramsey to slow down
deandre hopkins i i think even with
wolford at quarterback
not a lot's gonna change for that
offense and i still think the rams have
the advantage in the matchup
amazing to think the cardinals as good
as they were and i think it was six and
three after the halo murray game i
believe yeah uh i
and now they're looking at eight and
eight are you kidding me i know but uh
uh amazing slide by the cardinals and
those injuries that kylo murray has
sustained the shoulder and now the leg
i think uh the the final nail in arizona
uh and we'll see if they can regroup and
get it done next year washington
philadelphia sunday night football
washington is in with a win they would
win the nfc east with a record of seven
and nine and i'll host a playoff game in
the wild card round can washington win
this game chris if alex smith is unable
to go did not practice on wednesday
taylor heinecke would be the replacement
dwayne haskins long gone
do you think they can win without smith
yes but it'll take you know some other
factors heineken did look good when he
came in the other day now i know you
know the game was kind of over and all
that type of stuff too so it's different
as far as the intensity he'll have to
deal with at the start of the game and
everything like that so we'll see but i
think like yes they can win
but then to me it's gonna have to be all
right antonio gibson in the run game
were somewhat special and maybe the
defense you know caused a turnover or
two to give them a short field you know
i don't know if i trust the fact that i
think taylor heineke is gonna you know
execute and do all those things i hope
he can i just don't know i mean we
haven't seen him play enough football i
think that's the the big question to me
but the the other aspect that is
concerning too and just from what we
heard with alex smith right mike i mean
i would think he's playing if he was
that close to playing last week i would
think he makes it this week but um the
the other aspect that terry mclaren that
that's where i worry about maybe more
than anything for washington because if
they don't have him
there's nothing to worry about really in
the past game that way and then it just
lets the eagles really focus on antonio
gibson and do all that you know the
eagles got run on last week but it
wasn't till late in the game until they
were desperate and they were trying to
get the ball back they were okay
handling zeke elliott and company and
all that but ultimately they they broke
because they were trying to make
something happen and they got to worry
about all those receivers in dallas they
don't have to worry about washington i
think this is going to be a close
competitive football game
you mentioned terry mclaren he was in a
walking boot yeah weekend he didn't
practice wednesday gibson also didn't
practice he's been dealing with injury
issues turf tape the other dynamic here
chris
is the eagles have nothing to lose i
know eagles are loose the eagles this is
you know this is that
texans on thanksgiving
bengals on monday night a great week and
a half ago yeah where
this is our chance people are watching
kind of like a bowl game during bowl
week where
let's just show everyone what we can do
and this is jalen hurts opportunity to
really convince everyone that he's the
guy so i think this is a very very
dangerous spot for washington especially
if they don't have alex smith
i was going to say mike that's a great
go ahead though i think that has to be
talked because like philadelphia is one
of those teams and i think that's what
you're saying where
they're not i don't look at them as a
team that's going to go oh the season's
over we're going to give up i feel like
they're one of those teams that's like
let's try this this week let's do this
this week this is going to be fun let's
screw them over let's run this trick
play i think they're going to relish the
no pressure like you're saying to where
that is dangerous
yeah fake punts fourth downs right
gadget plays exactly and
with
look the closing argument for the season
is this prime time game
eagles fans want major changes doug
peterson has to at least be wondering if
it was so bad this year that he may not
have a job next year at least has to
wonder that
the best way to
to propel yourself into an offseason of
uncertainty is to win
national television prime time last game
of the regular season and keep
washington out of the playoffs that is
going to be your best footing for
whatever comes next and maybe avoid
what would happen if you end up losing
42 to 10 to washington in that spot now
before that game
we will know who gets in if washington
loses because the cowboys and the giants
have an elimination game at 4 25 p.m
eastern dallas six and nine at giants
five and ten whoever wins wins the
division if washington loses it's that
simple
the cowboys
really have gotten better
we left them for dead yeah and they have
found a way to wake up chris and i made
the joke when the rose bowl got
relocated to atd stadium oh well they're
gonna have a postseason game there after
they may have two postseason games there
because there may be 30 000 people plus
at att stadium watching
uh
the cowboys host the buccaneers next
weekend no i mean i know and dallas you
know to your point they have gotten
better there's no doubt i i don't sit
here and go oh they've gotten so better
though that i think it's a guaranteed
win against the new york giants
definitely not i know they've won three
in a row you know they were down last
week what 14 to three pretty early you
know they were fortunate in the two wins
before that cincinnati gave them the
ball and gave them like they just kept
handing the ball and
you know dallas's defense scored a
touchdown and then they got a short
field and the 49ers did the same thing
they've had some games fall their way i
do think the giants match up pretty good
with the dallas cowboys you know the the
issue with that it's just like can the
giants offense do enough can they run
the ball dallas's run defense stinks i
mean it's horrible can the giant that's
why i was shocked you know we talked
about in the first hour daniel jones
talking about i'm gonna play in the
pocket and i don't know you'll see the
similar game plan which means he can't
run and get on the edge but
that to me is gonna be you know the big
thing can the can they who wins that
much matchup did the giants gash them in
the run game
or does dallas kind of hold their own if
that's the case then i think dallas can
win the football game definitely but i
do think that giants defense can match
up with with dallas's you know uh
offense too
giants are those giant big guys up front
like we've talked about it should be a
lot like their seattle game plan five
big guys up front we're gonna play we're
gonna put all the pressure on our big
guys to stop ezekiel elliott in the run
game so we can play too deep
and not let cd lam amari cooper and
michael gallup go off because the giants
can't match up with those receivers
across the board there's no way so they
got to protect them with safety play in
my opinion well they got the biggest
d-line on football they're gonna have to
put the pressure on them to stop the run
so they can protect that i think they
got a chance i favor dallas but i think
this will be a close game
it was a very close game when they
played earlier this year 34-31 the
cowboys got the win at home over the new
york giants uh i think it was the
prescott
yeah it was one of the rare wins right
andy dalton came in and found a way to
get it done and speaking of dalton and
this is a point on a day when we are
bashing pete demolitis every chance we
can get i have to give him credit here
he has alerted me to this quirk of a
historical football fact
andy dalton five straight playoff berths
with the bengals in the afc never
crossed paths with tom brady once
this year it could be dalton in his
first year with an nfc team facing brady
in his first year with an nfc team in
the wild card round and that will happen
if the buccaneers win which they fully
intend to do and they're going to go for
it because they want to be the five seed
because they'd rather play at dallas
than at seattle or at green bay or at
new orleans and uh if dallas wins
if tampa wins and if washington loses
that will be the matchup
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports